foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
get pivoting right tips and tricks for
accurate and reproducible results this
webinar is part of the sixth annual
event for the drug Discovery and
development virtual event series and I'm
Susie Valdez of labroots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by Sartorius for
information about Sartorius please go to
sartorius.com so let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during this presentation you can
find the live chat located on the left
of your screen you can also participate
by submitting as many questions as you
would like during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation now
you will also notice that the sponsor
has provided a survey located at the
right of the ask a question box this
survey will be available for both the
live session and the on-demand period in
addition to asking questions we also
encourage you to participate in our two
poll questions toward the end of the
speaker presentation click on your
answer when the poll questions are
displayed on your screen now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located at the top of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby and finally as a reminder this
education presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits link located at the
abstract tab from the menu at the left
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain those credits I now present
today's speaker Kate Morgan Regional
business manager and lab Essentials emea
at Sartorius for a complete biography of
our speaker please visit the presenter
tab from the menu at the left of your
screen Kate welcome you may now begin
your presentation
thank you Susie and thank you um hello
and thank you to everyone for joining me
on this webinar
so
so today I wanted to share with you some
tips and tricks that we can use when we
are preparing to get accurate and
reproducible results I'm sure if you're
already working in a lab there'll be
some information that you already know
but I hope that I can share with you
something new that perhaps you didn't or
it likes to remind you of something that
you may have forgotten in this
presentation I'm going to break down the
sources of error and what we can do to
reduce them
so why is it important that we get to be
petting right
and the reason for this
is that if we take for example live cell
experiments we obviously when we put our
essays into an analyzing system for in
this instance the inky site we want to
make sure that we get accurate and
reproducible results out
however
these results will only be reproducible
and accurate if our sample preparation
is good
and in the case of live set experiments
pipetting can create many variances for
example in the cell seeding if we don't
mix well then we get bubbles if we have
a foaming liquid if we don't prepare our
volumes correctly in serial dilutions it
can have an effect and we need to
consider the temperature differences in
our liquids and the environment
so
which one of these two Targets is
accurate so we've got a and b and if we
look at a we can see the points are very
close together
but they're not really close to the
center of the target
whereas B the points are a little bit
more spread but so closer to the center
so which one is more accurate
well the correct answer is b as the
points are closer to the center however
we could say that a is more precise
but what we're really looking for is
accurate and precise so that we can
repeat those results
and just to explain that a little bit
more
a is showing very good results they're
accurate and precise
B the results are precise but they're
not really that accurate and this could
be down to our prepetting errors or
error in calibration maybe changing the
pet tip without calibrating the pet
first
C is showing accuracy results but
they're not very precise and again this
could be down to inconsistent pipetting
technique or not a great pipette and tip
combination and finally this picture is
showing neither accurate nor precise
um readings and this generally is down
to a leaky piston and cylinder system so
a lack of Maintenance or even very poor
tip
fitting
so now that we understand the difference
between accurate and precise and we
understand how they can affect our
petting and we're going to look at the
four different error sources and the iso
8655 which is a gold standard for
service states that there are four
surface sources of error
firstly put pets and tips as a system
then we have a petting technique types
of liquid and finally the environment
and we're going to look at each of these
individually to see how we can reduce
errors
so starting with pipettes and tips
the first thing that we're going to look
at is making sure that we choose the
correct pipette for the volume that we
are preparing
so the manufacturer so this
table is
um showing the manufacture
specifications for a tacta mechanical
pipette
um
just because on the pipette it's dates
of volume
um so for example you can see that we've
got
three different volumes here 100 to a
thousand twenty to
210 to 100 doesn't necessarily just
because it states that it can do a
hundred microliters within those volume
ranges doesn't mean that it'll be the
most accurate
so you need to make sure that you are
aware of the manufacturer's
specification
okay
and on this table we can also see the
maximum permissible systematic errors
and the random errors change depending
on the volume of the pipette
so if for example we were to use a
thousand microliter per pair for 100
microliters you can see that this
permissible system error is plus or
minus 2.5 microliters
compared to plus or minus 0.8
and this is a big difference
um it is always best to use the pipette
that has the maximum volume closest to
the volume that you're preparing so in
this example you would be best to use
the 10 to 100 microliter pipette because
it's 100 microliters that we're looking
to protect
foreign
so a leaky piston and cylinder can
create an error of up to 50 percent
and this is because Pistons can get dry
because the grease is one away or
O-rings will get worn with use and if
you're using volatile liquids that
release gases then also Pistons can
become eroded so this is happening on
the inside of the pepper and although
you use it every day you're obviously
not looking at the inside so it's very
important that you do have a maintenance
plan for your instruments where they are
serviced and calibrated regularly to
reduce this error
and tip compatibility
so it's obviously important that we use
the correct tips for yoga pets so just
because a tip fits does not necessarily
mean that you're going to get the most
accurate results and this graph shows a
Pecos 10 microliter of a pet with using
10 volume so as we saw in the last
um slide we're not using the best prep
for this volume but we just want to show
the difference between the different tip
types
so you can see that the Sartorius tips
are in yellow and from this graph you
can see that those give the most precise
results which is what you'd expect
because it is always recommended that
you use the manufacturer's pipettes and
tips together as one as one system
tips a are not too spread but there is a
little bit of systematic error but we
could calibrate that pipette to correct
this and tips B is neither accurate nor
precise
and so wouldn't be a good match so
although they may seem to be working
correctly actually they wouldn't
um they wouldn't be giving you accurate
results
so from that we can see that it's really
important to choose the correct to
prepare that we need to make sure that
our pipettes are serviced so that we can
get the best results and that we're
using the best for pets and best tips
with the best of the pet
so now moving on
to the next
source of error we're going to look at
pipetting techniques
and then for testing techniques there
are four areas that I'm going to look at
but so first of all I'm going to
introduce
then we'll look at perpeting modes
sources of preventing error and then
electronic pipettes
so first of all looking at why preparing
techniques are so important
so here we have another graph which is
showing the random error with different
volume mechanical pipettes and
it shows the different experiences how
much experiences the user have and you
can see from this graph
that on the right hand side those that
have had a lot of experience
and and time they have less Rhythm
errors that perhaps those that are
inexperienced
and what this graph illustrates is that
good preparing techniques are critical
especially to getting good results in
small volumes
so we'll move on to the different
pipetting modes and the first preparing
mode we're going to look at is the
forward pipetting now this is the one
that is most commonly used if you're
working in the lab with a pet so suspect
that this is the one that you're using
all the time
um this is the one that is definitely
used in Factory calibration and in
service
and it's very simple you push down to
stop one
you then release the plunger to aspirate
and then you push down step one to
dispense
and then to ensure that you have all the
volume you push down to second stop for
the blowout
but we also have an option of reverse
pipetting
so this is one that is less commonly
used or known about but it is very
useful especially for those difficult
liquids and that's something we're going
to talk about in a bit more detail later
now this technique has to be used
carefully as it's very easy to dispense
more than the volume that you acquire
and this is because
so first of all to aspirate you have to
press the plunger all the way down to
stop too
so you then lift the plunger to take up
the liquid to aspirate and of course at
that point you now have more volume than
you than you require
so to ensure that you get the correct
volume you push the plunger down to the
first stop
you then need to make sure that what's
left in the in the tip is dispensed into
a waste vessel and you obviously do that
by pleasuring the plunger all the way
down
so as you can see this requires a little
bit more experience and to be very
careful that we don't
um we don't dispense too much of the
volume but it is really useful
so we're now going to look at the
sources of pipetting error
so
here's a nice little table that tells us
how different prophetic techniques can
lead to standard deviation errors so for
example failure to write the tip on the
vessel wall leads up to three percent
and this picture shows nicely that beads
of liquid at the end of that pipette tip
and how if it's not touched against the
side of the beaker then you're not going
to get that as part of your volume so
you won't get an accurate result
um you can also look at if you fail to
pre-wet the tip and then fail to wipe
the tip on the vessel will then these
errors can add up
so all of a sudden you've lost five
percent and we're going to look at some
of these different pipetting techniques
in a bit more detail
starting with pre-wetting
so pre-writing is recommended by the iso
8655 standard to improve accuracy
and as you can see from the graph if you
don't pre-wet then the dispensed volume
will be smaller than the required volume
and this is because the liquid
and the Piston
um this because the liquid in the
episton isn't
um between the liquid and the business
sorry is an air column and liquid can
start to evaporate until the air becomes
saturated and the dispensed volume will
be correct
and as you can see after about three
pre-rinses
then
um
then we start to get the correct the
correct volume
because we're starting to saturate that
air column and obviously the drier the
the air is then the more pre-rinses that
you need to do
so if you're in a lab that requires that
has air conditioning you might actually
need to do about five pre-rinses
ever same is not true when we reverse
pipette and because as we talked about
previously the more liquids the
University of pipetting you take up more
liquid which means that that extra
liquid can be used in the evaporation
so another area that I wanted to look at
was aspiration so this is when the
passing angle when we are aspirating is
really important and can cause an error
of about one percent
so it's really important that when you
enter the tip into the liquid it's at 90
degrees as shown on that picture and
this obviously is zero on the graph
and the reason this is important is
because if you tilt the pipette you're
increasing the surface area inside the
tip so instead of it being a perfect
circle what you're actually doing is
you're creating an oval if you tilt it
so this will actually aspirate a larger
volume than set
um and this graph shows the effect of
tilting the the pipette tip
so up to if you wanted
um an a volume of a thousand microliters
by tilting it even you know
just 10 you're adding on that extra one
microliter and going all the way up to
about six just no just over
um five microliters at 60 degrees
so this can add
um some big errors to your results
so next I wanted to look at an even
piston movement
um and having an even and smooth piston
movement around for pitting in my in my
experience is actually perhaps the
hardest part
um and it does come with practice
um but also it's really affected by how
many hours if you've been petting all
day and you're tired or if you're in a
hurry because you need to get to do
something else it's really hard to keep
that smooth and even piston movement
so although actually it's not a big
error generally
um depending on what you're doing it can
have quite a big effect and a good
example of this is in cell seeding
so on the left hand side we have a graph
and this graph is showing the phase
object Confluence Against Time
and we have two lines that we're
particularly interested in we have the
yellow line
which is A1
or the the well A1 and we also have the
black line which is the well D5
and
if we look at A1 even at the start you
can see there are big differences
between the A1 and the D5 so A1 responds
to the picture
B on the right hand side and D5 responds
to the picture C
and there's already some differences you
can see that there are more cells in C
than there are than there are in b
but even after 72 hours of cultivation
the well A1 which is now image D has not
caught up with the world D5 which is
image e
um and this is due to inadequate miscing
which can be down to uneven piston
movement
um and it being jerky and of course if
you've got a jerky piston movement then
actually it can increase the cell
sharing which also has an effect on your
results
so finally in preparing techniques I
want to talk about electronic pipettes
so we've seen this graph before
um which shows the mechanical pipettes
and we we already know that with
mechanical pipettes
um the more experienced you are the more
accurate your results are going to be
but to help compensate that we can use
an electronic repair and this graph
shows that the magnitude of error with
different volumes
is actually similar
and that
the petting skills and experience
actually have very little impact
and this is down to the consistence
um electronic prepared piston movement
so that piston movement because it's
done electronically it's very smooth and
it can be done at set
um
can be done at set speeds so this
compensates for any petting tape
technique vaults that we have if we use
a mechanical
and pipette so it eliminates the user
experience
and also it also eliminates those
pipetting forces
so electronic pipettes
improve this pipetting accuracy because
because it takes out those differences
and experiences I've said and the
changes in petting techniques during the
day
and this graph on the left shows you the
difference between the total cumulative
Force per fitting cycle
When comparing a Sartorius prepare and a
mechanical pair and that poor lady in
the picture is holding her hand because
she's been petting all day
um and it's tired so that is also good
ergonomics to have electronic pipette
so the real advantage of electronic
pipettes is that they definitely reduce
the use to use variability in pipetting
and it allows everyone to reach that
expert level
um it also means that the error of an
even Rhythm and timing that's according
to the iso 8605 can lead to a two
percent increase in standard deviation
is eliminated
um because as we said the electronic
controls the Piston movement
electronic for pets we 've got some
extra pipetting modes
um so we have two that we're going to
look at here multi-dispensing and
sequential
dispensing so starting with
multi-dispensing this allows you to
dispense the same volume many times with
just one aspiration
so you take up a volume say you want it
to dispense 20 microliters into various
um containers you can take a volume of
200 microliters and then you can
dispense 20 microliters so that gives
you 10.
so if we also look at sequential
dispensing again this allows you to
dispense different volumes that have
been preset in real aspirations it
doesn't have to be the same volume you
could have
say 50 microliters then a 25 and then a
10. and both of these modes help you to
speed up the work that you do and reduce
errors
we also have the possibility of carrying
out dilutions so you can do this by
aspirating the dilutant and then you
have an air gap and then you aspirate
the sample or reagent
and all of these are only possible with
electronic pipettes
so having looked at pets and tips and
now preparing techniques
we're going to move on to looking at
liquids
and there are four liquids that I would
say ah challenging
um so as you can see we have viscous
liquids
hot and cold liquids volatile liquids
and foaming liquids and the first one
that we're going to look at
is viscous liquids
so as we all know because liquids have a
high resistance to flow and tend to
stick on the tip surfaces so they're
really hard to prepare and if you tried
you tend to get especially if you do it
quickly you tend to get air bubbles I've
tried to do it with honey and it's it's
really hard
so this graph is showing pipetting with
75 as well something that you're more
likely to use in the lab as opposed to
Honey
um and it's showing with forward and
reverse repeating using a mechanical pet
now the mechanical was used there was a
pre-rinse and the same tip was used for
each step
and we can see with the forage we're
petting there is a lot of variation
however with reverse for betting
or when you use a dispenser for a pet
also known as a positive displacement
prepared you do get better results
but also we can look at the speed
and with viscous
um with viscous liquids speed can have a
real effect
so looking at this bar chart one is a
slow for petting speed and eight is a
fast-pipetting speed
so we can see
that by using a slower cutting speed
we'll get a more accurate
result
so as we said the challenges are the
higher resistance to flow and the
tendency to stick on the tip surface
and for the best results you need to
either reverse repet or use a positive
displacement prepared and that your
aspiration and Spence needs to be done
slowly
and obviously that is easier to do if
you have an electronic pipette but also
we need to make sure that we dispense
against the wall of the vessel
so moving on to foaming liquids
so I'm sure you've all had experience of
of foaming liquids they are really
difficult to get accurate results as
soon as you move them they start to foam
and prepare them they yeah
um and again we've got this graph which
shows that before betting you get a lot
of variability
um and that again your best option
actually is reverse pipetting but again
to do it slowly
um I'd also recommend that you use
safety space tips
these have a big gap between the top of
the liquid and the filter so if you do
get foam in your tip it stops it from
touching the the filter
so moving on to another difficulty
um difficult liquid type and this is
cold and warm liquids now
ideally
we would want to prepare all liquids at
room temperature but this isn't always
possible and this is obviously because
you need to keep your samples at usually
at cooler temperatures from need to get
them straight out of the fridge or on
occasion a warmer a warmer temperature
so if we are preparing at different
temperatures
then the dispense volume can deviate
from the target volume
and this is due to a change in volume in
the air column so you can see from the
picture on the right that you've got the
liquid and the prepared tip and then
you've got this air column and then the
and then the piston
and this air column is very much
affected by temperature and by pressure
as well
so
if you're be petting
a liquid that is colder than room
temperature
and therefore it's going to be colder
than the air column then after the bit
of time the aircon tends to expand due
to this difference in temperature
so as you can see from this graph here
they've used the same tip they haven't
replaced it so
by using the same tip you obviously
you're keeping that air column you're
not it's not getting changed so that
means that it's expanding which means
that you're taking up less value
um
this volume and then the opposite occurs
with
warm liquids
so if the liquid is warmer than room
temperature
then what you're doing is that air
column is obviously cooler than your
liquid so it contracts and this means
that more volume is being aspirated
um more volume is being aspirated and
then therefore dispensed
so as I said ideally
we'd like the liquids to be at room
temperature but we know that that's not
always possible
so in these situations if you're
pressing cold and warm liquids we
recommend to not pre-wet the tips
because we don't want to give the air
column chance to expand or contract and
to make sure that we change the tip
after each dispense
so finally we're going to look at
volatile liquids
so
as I'm sure if you've ever prepared
ethanol you'll know that it evaporates
very quickly last time evaporates very
quickly so evaporation as we've talked
about this air column evaporation cause
the air column to expand which means
that you often get a dripping pipette
tip as you can see in this in this
picture
um and in these cases actually the
recommendation is to pre-ret the tips
so making sure that you saturate that
air column
you could also use reversible for
petting because if we use reverse
pressing if you remember we take up
excess volume and that means that that
excess volume can be part of that volume
that's lost in evaporation
and also we need to make sure that we
work as a consistent but rapid pace
so having looked at liquids
we're now going to move on to our final
aerosource which is the environment
and with this I really wanted to look at
um
at the kind of ergonomics
um so the environment that we work in
and make sure that we are
um
being ergonomic in what we do so we're
going to start off with the with the
workstation
so as you can see from this
picture
your workspace if you think of your
workspace as having two semi-circles
and the closest one to you is your
normal working area which should be
about 10 to 30 centimeters from your
table Edge
and your maximum working area which
should be about an arm's length so
ideally where you can comfortably reach
without over extending that shoulder or
bending from the back and this is
usually on average depending on you as a
person your height your arm length is
about 40 to 50 centimeters away from you
now you need to make sure that you're
most often used items like your samples
your pet tips your
um waste bin is in that normal working
area
and you're less frequently used items
like your other pipettes so
let's say you've got a rack of pipettes
that you're not using you want them in
your maximum working area so they're
there if you need to change your pets
but you're not constantly reaching for
them
so it's really important to think about
how you place all your items around you
so
obviously you're looking to stay in as
neutral position as possible so that we
avoid leaning and we don't want to be
leaning on our elbows or our forearms or
our wrists because this adds more stress
and strain and by reducing the stress
and strain it means that of course see
we keep our petting position comfortable
which means that obviously we're going
to have good preparing technique and
create those accurate and reproducible
results
so finally having looked at the
workstation we're now going to look at
biosafety
cabinets
so looking at ergonomics in a biosafety
covenant I've got a diagram here of a
cabinet and I've highlighted various
pieces of kit
um so obviously you can see we've got
the pipettes
um to the right hand side on this
diagram we've got our media bottles
we've got our tip boxes and we've got
our waste bin
so the reason that I've pointed those
out is because now I've got a little bit
of a quiz for you
so
thinking about what we discussed about
in the workspace and obviously those
areas of reach obviously with the
cabinet it's a bit more compact we
haven't got the space but we need to
create a good workflow so that we can
keep this clean and sterile environment
and we want to be able to work without
knocking things over Etc
so looking at cabinets a b and c
which do you think is the best cabinet
for a right-handed worker
so
the answer to this is actually the
rights and the
um as this is actually a
um because as you can see on the right
hand side you've got your pipettes
you've got your clean tea tips and
you've got your fresh media bottle
and after taking the clean reagents you
can move to work on the left hand side
where you've got your cell culture
flasks are there and then to the waist
and the trash
so
so to make the best out of a challenging
working environment
um so for example in a biological safety
cabinet it's really important to think
about the positioning of supplies
should
um and where you want things to be
closest to you
um so that we avoid reaching and we want
to make the workflow as smooth as
possible and obviously as we've said
frequently used items should be located
closer than the ones that are needed
more rarely put them at the back of the
cabin up
foreign
so
in summary
we've looked at four sources of error
for pets and tips so we looked at the
best pipette optimal tips
um different
and then the different pipetting
techniques so pre-wetting tips angle of
aspiration and then we moved on to
liquids so there's difficult liquids how
we perpet them so that we get the most
accurate results and finally looked at
the environment that we worked in and
how we can make sure that we stay safe
to allow us to prepare correctly and get
accurate results
so
just to recap pipettes our Precision
measuring instruments and you do require
experience and training
to to use them to be able to get
accurate and repeatable results
and just to show the graph on the left
shows how much variance there is amongst
even experienced laboratory
professionals when it comes to betting
and after some training you can see that
even those that have had loads of
experience they actually reduced the
variance in the group
so it's really important to continue
with training on on and continue
training on best prepetting
um practices
so we all know that right after training
all the new skills are freshly in our
minds
um but obviously we forget things and
with continuous training then it really
helps to to
um let those skills settle in and be
learned
so moving on to the poll
thank you so much Kate and we would
appreciate if our audience would
participate by answering a few
following
and we would appreciate if our audience
would now participate in answering a few
questions to record your uh answers
click on the option on the screen and
select all that apply
are you aware of the Sartorius pivoting
Academy yes
or no and I'll give you a minute to
select your answer
foreign
would you be interested in any of the
following pivot Academy topics
basic ergonomics techniques service
cell culture
nucleic acid
or proteins
and while you're finishing that up I
just want to thank you again for
participating in these poll questions
you may now continue Kate thank you so
much
so
um thank you so everything that I have
shared with you today has come from the
different pipetting Academy modules so
it's just been a very brief overview and
obviously those different modules were
mentioned in the poll if you'd like more
detailed training then I do recommend
that you take part and on the screen you
can see the address for the website to
find out more
um thank you so much for taking part in
this attending this webinar and I'm
happy to take any questions that you may
have
well I want to thank you again Keith for
that informative presentation and we
will now start the live q a portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have a few questions coming in
our first question which type of pivot
is more accurate Kate
okay so there are two principles of how
pets work we have the ad displacement
pipettes which we've spoken about today
and we have positive displacement for
pets
um most pipettes are used in
Laboratories work according to air
displacement principles
um based this is because they're widely
applicable and actually the consumables
are at a lower cost
so
grammatically it's
um but obviously air displacement as
we've shown today can also be used with
correcting techniques
um
we've also as we mentioned electronic
pipettes
these can eliminate a lot of the
variants from the petting and also
variance between users
and as we as we said
um the Piston movement is is controlled
so
I think it very much depends on what you
are doing
um depends on which type of pet is is
more accurate so that's something for
you to consider in your workflows
thank you so much and how do I know my
pipette is accurately dispensing
so the best way to make sure that you're
prepared is accurate expenses is
obviously as we said earlier regular
calibration and regular performance
checking and that's the only only way
and you can do a um convenient
performance you know you can do a
performance check in your lab and just
by using an analytical balance with a
moisture trap
um so and again that's that's talked
about in a pipetting academies if that's
something something you are interested
in but but really you need to make sure
that you do have servicing in place
thank you so much Kate and again I want
to thank our audience for participating
today we have one more question coming
in how can I improve my accuracy when
working with dilution series
Okay so we've talked about how pets are
very you know opposition instruments
tools and they require training
so when we're doing a dilution series we
need to make sure that we're following
the best bepetting practice and we're
look considering the liquid properties
um
that we're using to increase accuracy
and precision
obviously as we've talked about before
we can use electronic repairs and that
removes that whole user dependent
variables and obviously improves
um repeatability
um and obviously the dilation series you
you really need to make sure that all
your Solutions are properly mixed
and as I said again this is something
that's talked about in our competing
Academy trainings
okay I want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we go
just let's say thank you again for
everyone that's attended and if
there any more questions happy to help
well I want to thank you again Kate for
your time and your important research
and before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions I'd also
like to thank our sponsor Sartorius for
sponsoring today's webinar questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
February 22nd 2025
labyrates will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone bye-bye